If what I saw is true, war is on it's way.
We've got to fix this.
Okay.
But be lost forever.
Great.
This entire place is going to be destroyed
if one shot at this.
Whatever we do. We're playing God.
What could we have done differently?
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie.
This will be my Loki. Season
two Episode five Trailer Video.
Obviously there's a bunch of questions
and WTF of cliffhangers
they have to resolve from episode four,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Kevin Feige has been talking about them
doing Loki Season three,
but because there's been so much chaos
at Marvel lately behind the scenes
with all the different strikes
that's been affecting all of Hollywood.
but they've also been canceling
projects, then restarting projects
from the ground up like Daredevil born again.
They just hit the pause button
On announcing new stuff that they haven't
already been talking about publicly.
so even though this version of Loki
will continue no matter what
after season two,
we might also be getting Loki Season three
There are two more episodes as a me posting
this video, they said that season two has a
more definitive ending than season one, like
he doesn't see another statue of another king
and then they just cut to black.
like they'll be an actual ending,
but it won't be like the last ending
for the character.
They'll still be stuff that they're setting up
primarily Deadpool three, Avengers
five Kang Dynasty, Avengers
six, Secret Wars, that big stuff.
even though we have the Marvel movie
that's also coming out next week,
I don't think this is going to be
that connected
to what's happening in the Marvel's movie.
That's also connected to like Avengers
five Kang Dynasty stuff.
I'll talk about that in my videos
for the Marvel's movie.
but now a lot of you were like,
how do they get out of that situation
at the end of that cliffhanger,
at the end of episode four?
Because basically all of reality
collapsed on itself.
That was what was happening.
that's why when the timeline was exploding,
the wave washed over them
like Loki flinched and then suddenly
just jammed to black like boom, nothingness.
No sound, no nothing.
it was meant to represent all of reality
collapsing
like it was meant to be the void of nothingness
before the Big Bang.
That's why I made the reference to like,
no God of Symbiotes like.
And the judge says that he predated
the universe, predated the Big Bang,
Dark elves from Thor, the dark world
they came from before the Big Bang.
so they're like a couple of things
that actually exist in that void of nothingness
But thankfully,
the trailer footage has a bunch of scenes
that we have not seen an episode yet.
So clearly they do fix things,
at least temporarily.
my only guess right now
is that they don't actually fix things.
And it's just Loki's time
slipping the kicks back in
and he just slips back to a different time
earlier before
this actually happens that would explain that
the temporary Band-Aid on the situation.
So there's still like a ticking clock,
like we're still headed
for absolute destruction of reality.
but it just gives Loki a little more room
to try things a little bit differently,
to see if that will wind up helping things
What could we have done differently?
during the trailer, he's
talking to Örebro, saying,
what could we have done differently
to fix this?
Basically, they're kind of going full Doctor
Who this season with all the different time
travel tropes here.
one of the other funny things about the Doctor
Who series just in general
is that they're also known for
breaking their own internal logic all the time.
So don't be surprised if Loki does that to
they're also a lot of people that are wondering
if the Infinity Stones now work inside the TVA
because they turn the magic dampeners off.
People are like, Did Loki grab the time?
Stone
Is that how he gets out of this situation?
I don't think that's the case.
But the Infinity Stones might actually work now
so what they've done with the MCU
with like all the TV shows,
all the movies is they've changed the way
the Infinity Stones work,
like some of the rules behind how they work
from the way that they work in the comics.
then.
They did what if season one
and they had this whole twist where Ultron gets
the Infinity stones in, winds up
using them in a bunch of different realities.
So people are like, wait a minute, how do the
Infinity Stones work now if he's using them?
And all these different realities
across the multiverse?
the short answer is that people at Marvel
don't always worry about problems like that.
They just thought that it would be cool
to see Ultron using the Infinity Stones
across a bunch of different realities
like this would be a cool scene,
so let's just do it that way
and then try to explain after the fact.
and that just causes problems
with some of their other stories
because obviously the what if people weren't
really talking about that to the Loki people,
Either way, I do not think the time stone
is how Loki solved this situation.
I think it's just going to be as simple as time
slipping.
Like you look at all
these different scenes here
and you see all these different things
turning into spaghetti around them
and they seem way more chill.
So clearly it's at some point
before this winds up happening,
there's also a bunch of scenes of him
time slipping like to the jet ski dealership
all these other places here
there, scenes of him from what look like
the events of season one, talking to Mobius
about making hard choices
in the TVA prison suit.
now you're asking
if Loki is time slipping to the past.
Does that mean that Victor Timely
is still there and alive and able to help them
because there is some new voiceover dialog
from one of the Kang saying around and around
we go and also make the hard choice
in a different scene.
Think the hard choice. and around. And we go.
So that voice
might be more he who remains voice over
Not clear when it would be happening.
Like, is this them seeing him alive again,
or is this them just
watching another recording of him
like they saw in episode four?
Either way, we will probably see more
from a Kang variant in the last two episodes.
Like just because Victor Timely died
doesn't mean that's the end of the Kang's.
into answer the other question too.
I get a lot of questions about this
on a couple of previous videos.
What happens to the counsel of Kang's
if the timeline here is exploding
and all of reality is collapsing?
Does that also kill the counsel of Kang's
The answer is no, because the Council of Kang
is like the actual building
where they're assembling here exists
the same way the TVA exists in his own
little pocket dimension.
So it's also protected from changes
to the timeline.
there's brand new footage of Sylvie
fighting someone in he who remains the little
at the end of time using her magic.
So that might wind up
being her rematch with Ren Slayer
just because they're setting her up
is one of the big bads this season.
Indians or the other question
Ren Slayer got pruned,
so that meant she got sent to the void plate.
there's some footage here of her
in that same outfit on the Void planet,
just staring up at this bright light.
It's not clear
if a light still exists on the void planet
because of what happened to he who remains.
But he might still be there.
it seems like they stole her tempered
before she got pruned, though.
So there's a question
as to how she winds up getting back
Miss Minutes was taken offline briefly.
Eventually she'll find a way to come back
and if Loki time slots the past,
pretty much everybody would be alive again to
there are a couple other new scenes
like there's this weird scene of Hunter B-15
in the doctor's outfit
dressed like a doctor with a portal behind her.
It's unclear if this is like her regular life
on the sacred timeline because they're been
all these references to the characters
visiting their original lives on the time.
Like, don't you want your life back?
there's a scene of Cassie in the alleyway,
not really clear what he's doing.
He's also wearing a different outfit.
there's a bunch of scenes of Sylvie
looking at different places with things,
turning the spaghetti
like she opens the portal,
and it seems like this black
nothingness with spaghetti all around her.
So it seems as she tries
to go to a different point in the timeline
or to a different reality.
And there's just nothing
because the timeline exploded
At some point, the record shop
she's in here turns into spaghetti.
That might happen before that.
Regardless of what winds up
happening at the end of the season,
I think that Ren Slayer will wind up surviving
like I think they want to keep the character
around heading into Avengers five Kang Dynasty
because she's such a big part of the King
Comics just in general.
All the different Kane comics.
but I do think that Loki and Sylvie will wind
up defeating her and miss Minutes in some way.
So if anybody's going to die in this equation,
it would be Miss Minutes,
even though she's a program.
So it'd be more like
deactivating her permanently,
somehow just erasing all of her code.
But there's like the whole Ultron problem
because she's basically
like a more advanced version
of Ultron In Ultron is supposed to come back
during the Iron Man armor Wars movie,
so if he can come back, then wouldn't
miss Minutes also be able to come back
somehow that crazy little Leander age
is going to find a way to survive.
Just save a little piece of her code
somewhere buried across the multiverse.
if you want to save her for, like, some far
distant future story, you can always save her
for, like, a young Avengers story.
She worked really well on a story like that.
If you're going to do something
like the Iron Lad character eventually.
look at this cool program I found.
It's really good at playing chess.
And then, boom, slammed a black.
but everyone posts all your theories
for the next two episodes based on the footage
in all the trailers that we haven't seen yet.
Generally,
it does seem like Loki will save the TVA,
at least temporarily, because it has to exist
during the events of Deadpool three.
But we know everything winds up
leading up to Avengers five Kang Dynasty,
where the Council of Kangs starts making war on
all the regular Avengers in the 616 universe.
Some other multiverse characters do.
Then we know that by Avengers six Secret Wars,
everything is going to collapse.
They're going to do a version of Battle World.
Deadpool three Seems like it's a little more
connected to that, so I'm not expecting to see
a whole bunch of secret wars
related stuff until Deadpool 3.
I don't think the Council of Kangs is going to
be a huge character in the next two episodes.
But I do think there'll be some reference
to what's going on with them.
like I think they were trying
to keep Loki season 2
relatively self-contained
with just a couple variants of King.
There have been rumors about other variants
beyond the ones that we've seen so far.
But I think when it comes to referencing
the Council of Kangs will just be like
some loose references in
the finale Like, there is still the threat
of the Council of Kangs.
There's this king multiverse war
that we're going to see play out
during the events of Avengers
five Kang Dynasty.
I did a big Loki season two deleted scenes
video earlier because they revealed
a bunch of deleted scenes
for like a completely different storyline
where we actually would have seen
the Kang Multiverse War play
out over the course of Loki Season 2,
which would have been really cool.
they said that they basically saved
most of that for Avengers five Kang Dynasty
or a version of that, because what
they would have done during Loki Season
two had they done that, would have been
a much cheaper version of that.
like if you're going to show
a bunch of different Kangs
fighting all the Avengers characters across
time, you want to see like the Avengers
endgame level version of that, which is why
they saved it for the next Avengers movie.
there are a couple
brief references to it during Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania.
When Janet van Dyne was learning about Kang
the Conkers history.
Like she saw his mind.
She basically saw all the different wars
that he fought across space and time,
the different timelines
would you have to imagine that he was just
one of the more powerful versions of Kang.
So this is happening across
all of reality, all these different timelines
with many different variants.
My Full Episode 5 Video will post next week
after they release it
Other big reminder that Invincible Season
two is starting next week.
I'll do episode videos for that.
So I'll post those
after my Loki episode videos.
so click here for my Loki Episode 5
video did the link after
I post that and click here
for all my other Loki videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!